I'm going to come clean with you guys.
I'm sick of being laughed at.
Even though I didn't vote for the guy, I'm
sick of being the laughing stock on this planet.
The entire planet is laughing at us, making
fun of us.
We're the punchline of every global political
joke because of Donald Trump.
Now, his followers may not know or they may
not care.
Trump may keep telling himself and us that
we are the envy of the world, including on
our handling of Corona virus and testing and
everything else.
But it's not true.
And I am really embarrassed by it because
it's shameful to be this laughingstock.
The whole world thinks we're a joke because
Trump is a joke.
Anne Applebaum writes that in China, the official
Chinese news agency is pushing videos making
fun
of U.S. claims by Donald Trump that it's only
a flu.
Claims that are embarrassing to go back and
look at today.
That video has gone viral in Indonesia.
They wrote in disbelief about Trump proposes
disinfect an injection and U.V. rays to treat
COVA, 19 in France.
Reports say the rantings of Dr. Trump ridiculing
him once again in SouthAfrica.
An article promotes the horrors of U.S. President
Donald Trump, leaving people stunned and confused
with his bizarre suggestion that disinfectant
and ultraviolet light could be used to treat
the virus.
In Peru, a newspaper article called Attention
to Dr. Deborah Bourke's is visibly pained
expression as Trump wondered aloud about bleach
injections to treat corona virus.
And meanwhile, as the world laughs, Trump
insists, everybody looks up to us.
Everybody looks up to him on corona virus
and testing.
And everything we're doing here is Trump at
a
recent event making this case.
And we're going to lose a job like like nobody's
seen before.
And I spoke with Angela Merkel today.
I spoke with Prime Minister Arbi of Japan.
I spoke with many of the leaders over the
last four or five days.
And so many of them, almost all of them, I
would say all of them, not everybody would
want to admit it, but they all view us as
the world leader.
And they're following us.
You look at what we've done with ventilators,
we started.
This is one of two things.
Either a clueless person saying something
that they believed to be true, which is not
which was obviously not true or it's gaslighting.
It is making someone believe is making someone
question the reality by telling them something
that is completely disconnected from fact
if any of them are looking to us.
If other countries are looking to the United
States, it's to avoid doing what we did, because
almost every country has handled Corona virus
better than we have.
Russia now is becoming a mess.
It's a mess in Russia and they're rapidly
becoming one of the epicenters.
Russia may be handled this worse than the
United States.
We don't know yet.
It's early.
Brazil is becoming a major cesspool of Corona
virus transmission.
We know about Jaguar Ball Narrows skeptical
attitude towards the virus.
India is growingly growing a problem, not
growingly
is increasingly a problem when it comes to
the virus.
We'll see if they are able to turn it around,
but otherwise everybody would be looking to
us to not do what we've done.
They're not impressed with us.
We're not the leader here.
They're laughing at us.
Now there's a new report which says it's actually
worse than just laughter.
Laughter would be one thing.
There's a new report that says the world is
actually despairing because countries that
have become used to seeing the U.S. at the
table figuring out solutions.
Now we're seeing the U.S. as completely useless
because of Donald Trump.
European critics say it's not just that Trump
isn't helping like the United States normally
does.
Trump is eroding respect for the United States
and getting in the way of global cooperation
and solutions.
This has real world implications, and I want
to be clear
about that.
This is not a ha ha Trump segment.
Our global position is being destroyed by
this man.
Electing Trump in 2016 instantly called into
question.
The U.S. is being a serious country, but maybe
it was a mistake.
If Trump is reelected, it will cement the
United States as a joke and there's no other
way to say it.
If that happens, we are going to have to face
the reality.
That American voters are as much of a problem
as Trump himself and the people Trump hires.
Now, we suspected this for a while.
We've talked about it for a while, but it
will be the last confirmation.
If we reelect Donald Trump, we will know that
the disaster actually afflicts 60, maybe even
70 million people who may vote for Trump in
November of 2020.
The world is laughing.
A lot of people actually take pleasure
in that Trump ists who don't care about our
reputation around the world or they simply
tell themselves our reputation is great, but
this is not
good and
it must be stopped.